Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Let's have a look at this majestic technique
that is about style transfer for photos.
Style transfer is a magical algorithm where
we have one photograph with content, and one
with an interesting style.
And the output is a third image with these
two photos fused together.
This is typically achieved by a classical
machine learning technique that we call a
convolutional neural network.
The more layers these networks contain, the
more powerful they are, and the more capable
they are in building an intuitive understanding
of an image.
We had several earlier episodes on visualizing
the inner workings of these neural networks,
as always, the links are available in the
video description.
Don't miss out, I am sure you'll be as amazed
by the results as I was when I have first
seen them.
These previous neural style transfer techniques
work amazingly well if we're looking for a
painterly result.
However, for photo style transfer, the closeups
here reveal that they introduce unnecessary
distortions to the image.
They won't look realistic anymore.
But not with this new one.
Have a look at these results.
This is absolute insanity.
They are just right in some sense.
There is an elusive quality to them.
And this is the challenge!
We not only have to put what we're searching
for into words, but we have to find a mathematical
description of these words to make the computer
execute it.
So what would this definition be?
Just think about this, this is a really challenging
question.
The authors decided that the photorealism
of the output image is to be maximized.
Well, this sounds great, but who really knows
a rigorous mathematical description of photorealism?
One possible solution would be to stipulate
that the changes in the output color would
have to preserve the ratios and distances
of the input style colors.
Similar rules are used in linear algebra and
computer graphics to make sure shapes don't
get distorted as we're tormenting them with
rotations, translations and more.
We like to call these operations affine transformations.
So the fully scientific description would
be that we add a regularization term that
stipulates, that these colors only undergo
affine transformations.
But we've used one more new word here - what
does this regularization term mean?
This means that there are a ton of different
possible solutions for transferring the colors,
and we're trying to steer the optimizer towards
solutions that adhere to some additional criterion,
in our case, the affine transformations.
In the mathematical description of this problem,
these additional stipulations appear in the
form of a regularization term.
I am so happy that you Fellow Scholars have
been watching Two Minute Papers for so long,
that we can finally talk about techniques
like this.
It's fantastic to have an audience that has
this level of understanding of these topics.
Love it.
Just absolutely love it.
The source code of this project is also available.
Also, make sure to have a look at Distill,
an absolutely amazing new science journal
from the Google Brain team.
But this is no ordinary journal, because what
they are looking for is not necessarily novel
techniques, but novel and intuitive ways of
explaining already existing works.
There is also an excellent write-up on research
debt that can almost be understood as a manifesto
for this journal.
A worthy read indeed.
They also created a prize for science distillation.
I love this new initiative and I am sure we'll
hear about this journal a lot in the near
future.
Make sure to have a look, there is a link
to all of these in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!